[Music]
Heat.
We're good.
[Music]
Amen. Question
Hello. How is everyone today? So
exciting to see y'all. My name is Jared.
My pronouns are he, him. Um, I've got a
few announcements before we get into
worship today. So, um, I am happy you
are here. I'm happy our online friends
are here. Um, so quickly announcements.
Uh, May 25th, next Sunday, no service.
There's no service next Sunday. Uh, we
take off two Sundays a year. Uh, the
Sunday after Christmas or before
Christmas, I can't remember. It's in
here somewhere. after Christmas and
Memorial Day weekend so that our staff
and volunteers can have the weekend off.
So mark your calendars. No service next
Sunday. We will meet back here in two
weeks, not one week. Uh second
announcement, there is a opportunity to
help build a wheelchair ramp. Um we are
partnering with Texas Ramp to build a
wheelchair ramp for those in need. In
order to do that, we need to get a
better idea of how many of your lovely
faces would like to participate with
that. So, if you are feeling like that's
something you want to do, and I will
guarantee you, no experience needed with
that project. So, don't be afraid of
building something, somebody will help
guide you through that. Um, from the
wheelchair project, um, sign up on with
the QR code. Um, there will be more
information coming out on that.
Um, third, and very importantly, if you
were between the ages of kindergarten
and sixth grade, those aren't ages,
they're levels, but so what? Um, listen,
this is the time for you. Summer is
coming. So, water, sports, food, fun,
trivia, who knows what else Miss
Maggie's going to do. I had a great time
last year and I was an adult. So, summer
is coming on Saturday, June 28th in the
gym here at First United Methodist. We
will have a full day experience for kids
um kindergarten through sixth grade with
water activities, Bible lessons, crafts,
food, and fun. So, watch out for the
sign up coming
up. Third, oh, as we enter into service
tonight, we have an accessibility bucket
over to the left. Um that accessibility
bucket is if you are anxious about being
in a church setting, part of a
disability community or just feeling
fidgety. Uh we have a bucket over there
with tools for you, noise cancelling
headphones, fidgets, coloring sheets. We
just ask that you return them to the
bucket at the end of
service. And then finally, um as we
transition, we've lit these candles here
to my left and to my right as a presence
of the sign of Christ among us, fully
divine and fully human.
As we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry
and productivity, we enter the kingdom
of silence, stillness, and simplicity. A
sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship, and
adoration. A place to behold Christ,
revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation. Allow the unforced rhythms of
grace to find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
[Music]
But feel free to come with your whole
heart, your whole life, all the things
that we carry with us into this space.
It is welcome and wanted. Um so if
you're comfortable singing out or if you
want to sit and reflect or if you want
to raise your hands, um it is welcome
here. You are welcome here and we want
you to be a part of our worship
experience today.
[Music]
You are
not what you have
done or what
has been done to
you. You are something like the rising
sun. Can you
see you are
new? You
my father's
name will bear the
shame he left
behind. But there's new life flowing
through your veins. Leave some room to
be surprised.
You are
[Music]
new every
morning. You are
new every morning. Each day
resurrection waiting to break through.
[Music]
You could
try just for a
start to put the
judge back on the
[Music]
shelf. All the
loving
kindness in your heart. Have a little
for
[Music]
yourself. You are
new every
morning. You are
new every morning. Each day
resurrection waiting to break through.
You think hope is lost, but it's just
underground. The flame might be in, but
the fire won't go out.
All the evidence is pointing to the
truth. That daily resurrection is still
happening in you. You are
new every morning.
You are
new every
morning. You are
[Music]
new every morning.
You are
new every morning. Each day
resurrection waiting to break
through. You are
[Music]
You are
new. All right, kiddos. Y'all are
dismissed to go to your kids classrooms.
If y'all will meet your teachers over by
that door, they'll lead you
back. Thank you guys so much for loving
on these kiddos. We hope it's a good
night.
and we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people. Um, if it's your
first time with us tonight, um, this is
something that has been carried down
throughout Christian history and it's
really just an opportunity for us to
speak aloud the things that we've
carried into this space and to hold them
up together as a community before God.
Um, if you follow along on the screen,
you can read the parts in red aloud with
us and then we'll pause in the middle
for you to speak out a name or a
situation that's on your
heart. Jesus, for this city of Sax,
Texas, and for every city and community
and all who live in them, we pray to you
for the good earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence.
[Music]
Amen. We bring you the work of our hands
and now lay it down. Lay
[Music]
it. What we've done, what we built, what
we've
broken. Lay it down. Lay it at your
feet. You
hold it all, Jesus. You hold it
[Music]
all. Worried hearts, weary hands. weaken
bodies. Lay it down. Lay it at your
feet.
What we've used, what we've lost, what
we've
wasted. Lay it down. Lay it at your
feet.
You hold it all, Jesus. You hold it all.
You hold it all, Jesus. You
hold it
[Music]
all. All our dreams, all our plans, our
ambition.
Lay it down. Lay it at your
feet. And even if nothing comes to
fruition,
lay it down. Lay it at your
feet. Lay it
down. Lay it
at your feet.
[Music]
Therefore, as God's chosen people, holy
and dearly loved, clothe yourselves with
compassion,
kindness,
humility, gentleness,
and
patience. Bear with each other and
forgive whatever grievances you may have
against one another. Forgive as God
forgave you. And over all these virtues,
put on love which binds them together in
perfect unity. And let the peace of
Christ rule in your hearts. Since as
members of one body, you were called to
peace.
and be
[Music]
thankful. All my words fall
short. I've got nothing new.
How could I
express all my
gratitude? I could sing these
songs as I often
[Music]
do, but every song must
end and you never do.
So I throw up my hands, praise you again
and
[Music]
again. Cuz all that I have is a
hallelujah.
[Music]
And I know it's not much, but I've
nothing else fit for a
king. And only the heart singing
[Music]
hallelujah. Hallelujah.
I've got one
[Music]
response. I've got just one
move with my arms stretched
wide. I will worship you.
Oh. So I throw up my hands and praise
you again and
[Music]
again. Cuz all that I have is a
hallelujah. Hallelu.
And I know it's not much. And I'm
nothing else fit for a
king except for a heart singing
hallelujah. Hallelujah.
[Music]
Come on my soul. Oh, don't you get shy
on me. Lift up your song cuz you've got
a lion inside of those lungs. Get up and
praise the
[Music]
Lord. Oh, come on my soul. Oh, don't you
get shy on me. Lift up your song cuz you
got a lion inside of those lungs. Get up
and praise the Lord.
Oh, come on my soul. Oh, don't you get
shy of me. Lift up your song cuz you got
a lion inside of those lungs. Get up and
praise the
Lord. Oh, come on my soul. Oh, don't you
get shy of me. Lift up your soul cuz you
got a lion inside of those lungs. Get up
and praise the
[Music]
Lord.
Praise the Lord.
[Music]
Oh, so I throw up my hands. praise you
again and
again cuz all that I have is a
[Music]
holy
hallelu and I know it's not much but
I've nothing else fit for a
king except for a heart singing
[Music]
Hallelujah. Hallelujah.
God, in all the busyiness of our
culture, the back-to back
activities, the
hustle. God, we stop in this moment. We
pause to say thank
you for carrying
us, for walking with
us, for loving
us. Would we continue to grow in our
knowledge and understanding of who you
are and your love for
us? God, would it change the way that we
live?
Would we be different because of
it? Would we love
deeper? Would we walk more
humbly? Would we pursue
justice? Would we be a people marked by
your spirit?
A spirit that is good, that brings
life, that brings transformation and
redemption and forgiveness when the rest
of the world is screaming hatred and
pain and numbing. God, would we show up?
Would we be present and
ready to carry your love?
We are
grateful to be loved by you. We are
grateful to be your
children. We are grateful to gather in
this
space and remind one another of your
great love.
do your good work in our hearts,
God. It's in your name we pray.
Amen. Right. Um would you turn and say,
"The peace of Christ be with
you. All
right. Well, we are going to transition
here really quickly to before we get on
to the sermon and the rest of the uh
service, I'd like to ask three young men
from our community to come up who are
graduating seniors this year. So, yes,
welcome them with me. Matthew Miner,
Preston Livingston, and Nate Murphy.
Will you guys make your way up here,
please? Um, so these guys, um, actually
two of you are WY High School grads,
right? You're East. Okay. Okay. So, WY
High, WY East, and then Nate Murphy is
homeschooled. Y'all want to come up on
the top platform and that way it's all
the same for the videos? And then
Marissa's uh gonna come up here and join
us. But um basically we don't want to
let such a
monumentous occasion as this pass
without getting the opportunity to bless
you guys, to support you, to encourage
you, and just to tell you how much you
mean to us as a community. And um it has
been our tradition these last few years
to gather some words from your peers. So
we're going to take some time to share
with you guys um from some of the
leadership here and peers things that
they've said about you guys. Um, and
we'd like to speak a blessing over you
as well. And, um, we're doing this.
Y'all pretend like Michael's up here as
part of our youth team. He is um,
actually on his way to California
supporting supporting his sister getting
brain surgery. So, it's kind of a big
deal. But, he wishes he could be here
and he did ask me to please share that
with you guys on his behalf and he
contributed to some of what we'd want to
share. Before I share um, what other
people have said about you guys though,
I just want to take a minute. could you
tell us what your plans are from here so
that we kind of know how we're
supporting you and what we're supporting
and all that kind of stuff. And I'm
gonna give the mic to Matthew first.
Just let us know what are you pursuing
from here and what are your hope what
are you hoping for the future. Hi, I'm
Matthew. I'm next I'm going to the
University of Memphis and I'm studying
jazz performance. So that's what I got
going on.
I'm Preston. Hello. I'm Preston. I'm
going to&m studying aerospace
engineering. So,
I'm Nate and I'll be looking into trade
schools and electronics.
So, um Matthew I've known since he was
very young and I still remember when we
started the table. I mean, it's crazy to
think what a different person you were
then. Like looking back, he was much
shorter, didn't have facial hair for one
thing. Like his hair was not this poofy.
It was just a different human being. And
at that time, all I would ever um I
would be just driving and see Matthew
like at a local park like shooting
hoops, playing tennis, doing anything
sports related, going to sports camps
during the summer. And then slowly it
transitioned this love of music like
seem to engulf you and take you over and
it's been an amazing ride to watch and
it's exciting to watch you pursuing your
dreams in that. And then for Preston I
just wanted to share because some of you
guys might not know um Preston served
for years in our kids ministry. Um he
would be back there in our big kids
class and I mean I could count on him to
just like take everybody out to the
playground and play uh what was that
football game that they always wanted to
do with you? Um jackpot. Yeah, exactly.
Any I mean we had a host Julie his mom
would be back there with it was like 17
boys and two girls. It was the energy
levels were through the roof and we were
in that little building over at Pleasant
Valley United Methodist Church where you
could hear everything through the walls.
So Preston was in there with us trying
to help keep the chaos to a minimum and
he served in our summer programs um at
Summerramama multiple times um I think
three years in a row. Um and I'm truly
grateful for the ways that you invested
in the kids here and set an example and
it means a lot and I'm really so proud
of who you've become um and excited
about your future. And I just want to
say for Nate, our journey has just begun
with you. We've only gotten to know Nate
this past year, but he's been attending
youth for the um last several months.
And the kindness of heart that you
experience when you are with Nate is
absolutely so touching and leaves such
an impression on you. Um so on that
note, I just want to share what other
people are saying about you.
Um Matthew, y'all stood in order and I
didn't even tell you to.
Matthew, the words that your peers and
other adults here at the table said were
disciplined and motivated, diligent and
wise, a musician and a brother, a son
and a friend, a well of wisdom, fiercely
determined, ridiculously talented and
empathetic.
Preston, they said, he's easy to talk
to. Preston is disarming. He's honest
and direct. He's
open-hearted,
joyful, willing to serve, infectious
positivity that brightens any room. He
has a great smile and good poise,
genuine and
confident. Nate is humble and gracious.
He is teachable,
sincere, calm, and kind. He's the ace in
the hole. He's eccentric. He's a great
brother, attentive, quietly kind, and
warm-hearted. I'd like to also just read
one scripture over you guys, and then um
I'm going to ask Marissa if she could
take over and help me pray for these
guys. Um but this is um we Oh, just so
you guys know, in your gifts, everything
that was is being set up here, we've
written that down for you to have for
later. um in um your gift bags. But um
this is become one of
my favorite scriptures. Um and anyone
who's in youth has heard me talk about
it before, but um it's from the book of
Galatians, and I'm going to read the
message
version. It says, "Make a careful
exploration of who you are and the work
that you've been given, and then sink
yourself into it.
Don't be impressed with yourself. Don't
compare yourselves with others. Each of
you must take responsibility for doing
the creative best you can with your own
life.
Um, I feel like that that verse not only
just kind of lays out this, you know,
kind of guidelines for worship and what
worship is is living life well, living
this one life that God gave you well and
figuring out like who am I and what are
the gifts I've been given and how can I
give those back in worship. But also, I
just love that it talks about like don't
be too impressed with yourself, but also
don't compare yourself to others. Like
those are two sides of one coin and both
directions lead in such a terrible way.
Just know if there's anything that our
community that you're enough just as you
are. But we love who God made you to be.
We see it. We celebrate it and we
encourage it to like grow and grow and
fan it into flame. So if there's any way
that we can be here to do that for you
as you go on from here, we're in. We
will always be here and happy to support
you. So we want to pray over these guys.
Guys, if you guys would bow your heads
with me, um then we'll get to the rest
of our service. Can I hand this over to
you? Heavenly Father, I pray that these
young men know just how very loved they
are, how very supported they are, how
excited we all are for them this new
chapter as they embark on new journeys.
I pray that they have the confidence to
go forth, to explore these new
opportunities, to enjoy the
opportunities before them, and to have
fun. We ask that you be a light under
their feet and the foundation upon which
they rely as they go forth. It's in your
holy name we pray. Amen.
[Applause]
Grace and peace. So good to be with you
all and uh yeah it's a joy a joy to be
to be here and to be together and I love
that that those moments those moments
are really they matter you know I mean
you have these uh it's like all of
matters of course but like some moments
really matter some transitions are like
kind of a big deal you know and uh and
that's one of those and uh we're so
proud of you you guys and um yeah and I
thank you as a community for supporting
them and loving them being there for
them. So, um I'm gonna uh go ahead and
uh jump right in. So, we are in uh part
three in our series right now titled
Enchanted: Reclaiming Sacred Ground in a
Disenchanted World. And so kind of our
our big idea uh for this series is that
we we live in um really kind of an
increasingly secular world that's uh we
talked a lot about this last week in
particular that it's kind of um trying
doing its best to move away from what we
might call kind of classical religion so
to speak but it's just kind of
transitioning to other uh kind of almost
infusing religious ideas into things
like nation states and economic systems.
capitalism, you know, whatever, like and
kind of treating those as next um kind
of main thing. And uh and this is really
problematic um
because kind of an unintended effect of
that is that we end up kind of draining
well once we kind of try to leave God
behindness and uh meaning and kind of
the depth dimension uh of life uh out of
uh like almost all sorts of really
important areas. So in the series we're
kind of going through just different
topics and saying like how is kind of a
secularism how is it touching that and
kind of um ruining it and how might we
uh kind of revitalize and reimagine and
re-enchant it um knowing like God is
Christ is spirit is and like stuff
matters you know and so that's that's
kind of the the heart of this uh this
series so the title title of my message
uh tonight is re-enchanting sex and uh I
don't see any like super young kids so
just in case there's like this wouldn't
be you know their kind of message uh you
can send them on to kids ministry but um
you know Christians I'd say Christians
really across the board we're in a very
weird place with sex so like on the one
side you have kind of Christian kind of
conservatives uh really in both
Protestant and Catholic wings of the
church that seem largely to kind of have
adopted a rather kind of shrill culture
warrior kind of stance, you know, where
like we're just they're just not willing
to have what I would call like kind of
serious um nuanced discussions. To be
clear, I'm not saying every conservative
Christian is like that. I'm just saying
like that feels like the vibe, the
majority. That's kind of the the stance.
is just like I'm not going there. I'm
just going sort of politically against
you. You know what I mean? And that's
kind of the So it's like there's not a
lot of, you know, common ground for
dialogue, you know. Um
so yeah, so this I I think this is, you
know, obviously kind of troubling. I
mean and and just kind of frame it up a
little bit more because there have been
such
monumental shifts in the
culture like you know sexuality whether
we're talking about the effects of the
pill you like that was a that was a big
deal for the world and and for our
culture uh or the ways we're kind of
realizing we've terribly uh as a broader
culture but and also as like religious
communities mistreated LGBTQI plus folks
you know, and just kind of on and on.
There's just there's these kind of
ripple effects. Even folks just marrying
so much later, you know, not not uh, you
know, people marrying at 18,1 19, but
now it's sort of like 23 and then 25 and
27 and then 31 and you know, this this
all kind of comes together to uh kind of
push us towards like there's some
conversations that need to happen here.
But again, there's a whole kind of wing
of the church where they're like not
going there.
Um, now here's kind of the the trick I
would say the difficulty we face and
it's this is really where I'm going to
primarily address or this is the
audience or the the I know us as
community. So this is who I'm going to
be speaking to in this message isn't so
much that that group. instead. Um, I'd
say the challenge with for most
Christian progressives is that we really
I would say we really don't seem to have
much of a sexual ethic at all.
Um, well, there's a a quote I'll read.
This is from Richard Beck, who by the
way is coming from a more kind of
progressive Christian standpoint. And he
says this, "The main worry of
progressive Christians about sex is
shame and stigma. often originating in
Christian purity culture. Consequently,
the good news about sex from progressive
Christianity is a sex positive message
that has nothing to say about sex beyond
the ethic of the sexual revolution. Get
consent and do what you will. Don't let
shame or guilt get in your way.
In other words, like I'm just kind of
imagining if like a really thoughtful
young person were to come to me and say,
"Okay, Brett, so um I'm not a Christian,
but I understand that you, you know,
Pastor Brett, you are, and I get you're
not part of the kind of shrill culture
warrior, you know, wing of the the
church. Um I get you're against, you
know, purity culture and um all that.
Glad I get your LGBTQ affirming and you
know. Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. But what I'm
uh what I'm wondering is like how does
being a Christian make any difference in
your life when it comes to sex and
sexual ethics? Like in other words, are
you pretty much just like a good
liberal? You know what I mean? Like just
sort of that's just where you are and
like for anyone else out there in the
culture. Or is there something
different? Is there some nuance or
perspective or you know is your is
following Jesus is this is this
informing um your sexual ethic in any
way? And I think kind of to Beck's point
um it seems most not all but most
progressive Christians seem to be in a
place where really the answer to that is
no. You know in essence um we really
don't have much to kind of um offer
beyond that. I would say were a little
bit like um reminds me a little bit of
the conversations that I've my well when
I was there and my atheist friends have
um where like just as an example like
they're really good at critiquing
religion you know and that's kind of
like their jam and the thing they get
excited for and they're passionate about
it and they are good at it too you know
like they know all the points and the
things and the soft spots and you know
what I mean they can do that um but then
you say well okay I get I get I get that
but like help me paint me like a
positive vision like where what are are
you for? not just what you are against,
what are you like for when it comes to
sort of the world and living and ethics
and culture and you know what's what's
the positive vision here and they're
kind of a little bit
like you know it's not as smooth
suddenly in essence this isn't that's
not their jam right their jam is
critiquing religion like that's even
they're comfortable there aha and I
think this is the perfect parallel to us
as progressive Christians We are, it is
our wheelhouse to to uh critique purity
culture, you know, I mean to to kind of
critique a conservative sexual ethic and
the way that's played out and we're just
like guns are blazing, you know, like
this is problematic. This is hurting
people, you know, all the things. But
again, if someone asks us to kind of
shift and paint a more positive vision,
not just what we are
against, but what we are for when it
comes to sex and sexual ethics and such.
and suddenly, you know, we're a little
tongue tied. Like we're kind of like,
uh, well, I'd rather just talk about
what I'm against, you know, that's where
I let me tell you, I got a about that,
you know, um, we're we're just more
comfortable there. And, uh, and so
again, we kind of just tend to default
to something like,
well, get consent and do what you will,
you know, or something like that. So,
um, so in short, I'd say kind of
progressive Christians just tend overall
to have a very thin sexual ethic that
kind of struggles to account for the uh,
the emotionally laden, the relationally
enriching, the sometimes excruciating,
vulnerability inducing um, thing that
sex is.
So the of course one of the challenges
though is that in in kind of keeping
with the series is that uh sex has been
in the broader sense it's been kind of
reduced
uh disenchanted you might say it's been
uh commodified right in other words
everyone's making a buck off of sex.
It's been pornographed if that's even a
word. I'm not sure but uh it should be.
It's been instrumentalized, right? Where
people are kind of turned into like
tools, you know, into things, objects
for my kind of pleasure rather than
something, rather than someone really
like holy, holy,
holy. I I will say though, there's signs
I think uh I don't just mean the church.
I'm really meaning the broader culture
actually that things are kind of
shifting there. There's like change in
the waters. I'll never forget my shock
when like this is probably a good year
ago or so. I just came across this
random, you know, Instagram reel and uh
it was this video of a woman. She was
like giving off very like spiritual but
not religious vibes. I think there was
like some crystals and stuff, you know,
and um and it was kind of she was using
like certain spiritual lingo and such,
you know, but not Christian language.
And I was like, what what's going on?
And then she it was interesting because
she started talking about sex. And I
don't I didn't like write down exact
quote, but I remember the the kind of
idea was she was basically she was
saying, well, she said something to this
effect. She was like, um, my friends, if
you're listening to me, do not sleep
with just anyone. She said, ' Remember,
you are energy and when you sleep with
another, you mix energies with them and
are forever bonded to them. And I was
like, "Oh my gosh, this is like my
purity culture teaching that I heard.
It's like coming. It's like coming back
around, right?" It was sort of the the
woo version of purity culture. and uh I
recognized it. Now, you may feel like,
well, that's problematic. You know,
that's a quick road back to the shame
and judgment um kind of standpoint. The
only point I'm making is simply that
even
non-Christians are kind of picking up on
the sort of
disenchantment of the present age and
the disenchanted view of sex that we
often kind of default to. And and I
think for many of them it really um it's
not really making sense of their
experience. You might say that we've
kind of swung that pendulum, you know,
so far the other direction and in trying
to get away from I think like things
that needed to be gotten away from the
kind of intense shame and stigma and you
know freaking out, oh my god, you know,
and kind of getting away from that, but
we've kind of turned it into like, oh,
it's just sex. Hey, just it's just sex,
you know, and that's uh ends up kind of
being a little problematic
um as we'll get into that can because
that can end up really hurting people
because if it's true, you know, that you
aren't just like a human being
occasionally has these random weird
spiritual experiences, but you are in
fact uh a really profound spiritual
being to your core, right? You're not
just this like just flesh blood, but you
you have a spiritual body and a soul and
all that. Well, then right anything we
do um including sex is is there's
something deeply participatory about it,
right? We are we're kind of um we're
we're tapping into things. We're we're
participating in kind of bigger
realities and things that that do that
influence and kind of impact us. And uh
to kind of give uh a hint of kind of
where I'm going, I would say I think a
lot of this has to do with the the
powerful and really the the deeply
spiritual nature of desire because I
think desire ultimately is actually from
God and and leads us eventually back to
God. This I'd say in my opinion this is
really where some of the best minds in
Christian theology today. This is kind
of where they're headed uh when it comes
to Christian theology and sexuality uh
and sexual ethics. I'm thinking of folks
like um Graham Ward, Sarah Kley, Rowan
Williams. Um, but it's I will say it's
been for quite a while though in kind of
Christian theology and history it's
become kind of popular to um to kind of
separate out this would be like trying
to the 20th century take on like
Christian sexual ethics was kind of this
parsing out and separating of the the
four Greek words for love uh three of
which are found in scripture. So the
first is stoay. Um this would be like
friendly love. You know notice you got
Romans 12:10 for example. Be devoted to
one another in uh pho stogos. So that's
kind of an version of stoay. And so
that's yeah like like friend love. And
you have fileo. This would be like
family love. So Matthew 10:37. Anyone
who fileo who loves their father or
mother more than me is not worthy of me.
Jesus said. Or you have agape. This
would be the the kind of most prevalent
term in scripture, a kind of
unconditional love. John 13:35, by this
everyone will know that you are my
disciples if you agape or love one
another. And then finally, you have aos.
This is of course sexual love. And
that's not mentioned in the New
Testament. And so perhaps for that
reason,
uh, as kind of Christian history went
on, especially in like the 20th century,
this was the kind of perspective or this
was this was the Greek word for love
that was most kind of held at kind of a
distance, you know, sort of
like shirt about this, you know, and uh
it was almost like the view was sort of,
you know, agape love, that unconditional
sacrificial love that heavenly kind of
love, you know, from God. And and then
aos that's kind of kind of earthy, you
know, and and and with the sexual
overtones and such, it was that was the
seen as the more kind of suspect one.
Um, however, uh, folks like Sarah Kley,
Graham Ward, others, as they've kind of
read the church fathers and even the
Christian mystics, so kind of going back
in Christian history, they started to
kind of rediscover that actually, um,
this really wasn't this wasn't how a lot
of early Christians were thinking about
aos. Um, and and it really wasn't how
they understood um, well, maybe way to
put it is that they didn't see aos as
simply being about sexual love.
rather it's the kind of desiring longing
um kind of intense feeling element
happening in all forms of love right so
it's seen most evidently in a kind of
sexual love but it that doesn't mean
it's it's aos is just somehow like not
in agape say um the way the Christian
theologian writing in woo this is like
an early Christian theologian Gregory of
Nissa um in the first few hundred years
of Christian faith. He said this, "For
agape that is strained to intensity is
called
aeros." Agape that's strained to
intensity is called aeros. In other
words, there's a touch of aeros in all
agape. There's a touch of aeros in all
fileo, right? There's a touch of aeros
in all
stoay. And in fact, you know, far from
being kind of like
unspiritual, you know, um unworthy,
being somehow unworthy of God, aeros,
which from which we get obviously the
word erotic in English, um is precisely
that kind of love they said with which
we love
God and God loves us. Right? In other
words, like this is no um kind of old
love. This is no obligatory love. You
know the duty of love like no no no
which is what by the way agape can
become without what without any aeros
right it's it's almost uh yeah the duty
like I I love you I'm I'm committed to
you but um but I don't feel anything
towards you right that's where kind of
agape starts going So really another
word for aeros could simply be um
desire, right? Aeros is the desiring
aspect in all love. And again, it can be
sexual um but but it isn't always like
think of the way um the way a parent
loves their child, right? This isn't a
kind of like, well, I love you. I'm
yeah, I'm there for you. you know, or at
least at its best it shouldn't be. Um,
but you could imagine someone who's all
like they're going to love in really
sacrificial ways or a parent. But it
would be weird if there was no like
feeling desiring element like I am so
for you, you know, like I I love you
like crazy. You that's the that's a kind
of aeros happening there. or uh even
among like friends, you know, when
someone's gone and we say something
like, "Oh my gosh, I miss them." Like,
"I miss them so much." Or someone even
comes back to church after they haven't
been here in a while. It's like, "Oh my
gosh, I haven't seen you in I missed you
like crazy." You know what's that?
What's going on? That's more than just
agape like, "Hey, I'm committed to you
in this relationship." You know, that's
no, it's it's the it's the feel. It's
the it's the desiring element um in all
love. That's that's aeros. And this is
why um the Christian
mystics often sound quite almost
awkwardly erotic in their language for
God.
Um this is why I'm also I'm all for
Jesus is my boyfriend music. I know
that's not popular and like progressive.
we're kind of we're too cool for that,
you know. But I actually think like
that's what is that's er that's that's
the that's how kind of it's supposed to
be, right? There's a there's a feeling
element in our love for God, right? And
that means aos is present. And uh and
and of course, I mean, who do you think
is the source of all desire
itself? God, right? So, so there is a
sense in which when we feel a kind of
love, a kind of desire and such like
we're we're connecting to we're we're
somehow mysteriously participating in
like God spirit. It's like present in
that and and of course we experience
that aeros in both sexual and in
nonsexual ways. But the point is we're
we're kind of in that moment we're
mirroring God's desire for us, our
desire for others, their desire for us,
their desire for God. It's it's like um
all kind of happening there. So this is
where I think our kind of sexual ethics
should begin as Christians. We might say
that erotic love, desiring love is good,
good, very good. Right? Right? And I
think this is what progressive
Christians get right. Right? I do think
God is sex positive. I think Christ
should be sex
positive. But
um but what's the danger? The danger is
that aeros without agape, right? In
other words, without a kind of
unconditional
um unselfish would be a great word in
sexual ethics. a kind of
sacrificial I I am not just in this for
me. I will the best for
you. like now we're getting to a kind of
Christianlike love in general, agape
love, but also now we got a shot at at a
kind of um deeply rooted
beautiful kind of divine uh sexual um
not only just ethic but but even a kind
of sexual love. So we might say that
aeros without agape can indeed take us
to very dark
places. In other words, if agape without
aeros becomes sort of weirdly cold and
beautiful, you know that I love you but
just cuz Jesus told me to, you know,
something. Um well, what's the reverse
of that? Well, like right.
Um well, aeros without agape becomes I
want, I crave, I
desire, but I will
use whoever I have to to get it.
Right? This, of course, um this is where
things get sideways sexually, right?
It's the I think we might call it the
the shadow side of the sexual
revolution. And
uh there's a a book that I think would
be really worth reading if you're a
reader of books and into that sort of
thing. It's um by written by a feminist.
What's interesting is it's not written
from a Christian perspective or
Christian theologian or whatever. It's
written by a feminist named Luis Perry.
It's called the case against the sexual
revolution.
and uh her critique it's it's kind of
interesting because um in essence even
though she doesn't use the language of
course of aos and agape and you know all
that Christian theology but I think some
of the heart of what she's getting at is
she sees this playing out in the culture
and she's disturbed right because she's
seeing that if you have a kind of quote
sex positive culture right aeros
positive but you've
forgotten that
agape agape love, sacrificial love, it
has to go um right with it, you know,
has to be paired right with it. If
you've forgotten that a kind of
unconditional commitment to the
well-being of the other, if that's no
longer
emphasized, uh oh, you know, like was
that Scooby-Doo rut? Like it's a
problem, right? And and and it's going
to it's going to play out, right? And in
essence, lots of people are going to get
hurt. And I think as we kind of survey
the broader culture, um, I think there's
been a lot of upsides to the sexual
revolution, but I would say one downside
has been this kind of decoupling of
aeros and
agape. And uh, and so yeah, a lot of
people are getting hurt. The way I might
kind of sum it up is to say this would
be my critique of hookup culture. say
hookup culture just tends to be it's
pretty much you know it's about aeros
like it's all aeros and there's just
very little you know I will the best for
you and I shall show it by my months and
maybe even years of commitment I mean
just by the nature of it there's no time
to establish such a thing you know what
I mean and this becomes really um really
problematic all aeros know agape and sex
without that kind of commitment and
sacrifice can eventually come to feel,
you know, kind of just empty and uh and
even at its worst, I mean, downright
abusive, right? People feel used. And
so, for that reason, I I see hookup
culture as very much um kind of a dead a
dead end sexually. Um there's actually
there's some interesting sociological
kind of data on this. um even those who
rank super highly in what's known as
socuality which is an interesting term I
learned it from that book the case
against the sexual revolution but
basically socioexuality is those who can
just kind of enter into like very casual
uh uncommitted sexual relationships
without feeling a lot of like internal
angst and attachment
um like it's not the majority of humans
are not like which is sort of this is
part of the challenge of hookup culture
being so pervasive. It's almost like
everyone's expected to do this when only
the minority of people actually sort of
can end any way without constantly
getting driven crazy by like forming an
attachment. I wasn't
supposed like freaking out because
they're not texting me back and you know
it's like this whole kind of it's just a
real problem. But even those who rank
high in socioexuality, right? So they're
do that without feeling like you know
and freaking out. Um even those well
let's just say it doesn't age well. Um,
in essence, when those folks are kind of
put asked in surveys and such about
their own kind of psychological
well-being, they end up expressing a lot
of regret towards the end of their life
because what they feel like they've had,
well, basically it was a bunch of aeros
but no
agape. and uh they rank lower in terms
of mental health and well-being than
folks who don't rank high in that or who
don't kind of actually participate in
that kind of life for, you know, years
uh and such on end. And
uh yeah, I think that's kind of the the
way this can play out, you know, when
you
emphasize that that kind of all aeros
but but very little agape. I I'll close
with this story. I was fascinated to
come across a written interview with the
uh the rock star the sex symbol himself.
My god, Lenny Kravitz. This man is 60
years old now. Look at some of these
pictures. This is ridiculous. Like oh my
gosh. But I was f he he opened up in
this um that's a handsome man. I admit
it. Um he opened up about some of his
sexual history in this like magazine
kind of interview and uh it was
interesting. He said he he always had a
problem with his father. So, his father
was apparently like I guess his mother
was like actress and then television
producer dad and they like met and um
but he figured out pretty early on that
his dad was like cheating on his mom. In
fact, he caught him one time on like the
phone talking to his mistress and he
called him out and uh his his dad his
father's reply to him was really
telling. He looked at Lenny and he said,
"One day you'll do it,
too." And uh sure enough, that's kind of
how it played out. He like Travis grew
up. He got got married, became super
famous and eventually did kind of step
out of side of his marriage and then he
said that ended up you know collapsing
and and then he said I kind of honestly
after that I just went a little I went a
little crazy. He's like I was becoming a
player and he said but over time he said
I I didn't like it. He said, "I don't I
I didn't want to be that
person." And uh he said, "I had to
tackle that." And uh it took me many
many years. But what really struck me is
what what he said next. He said um he
said, "I've actually decided to be
celibate until I'm in a committed
romantic relationship, maybe even a
marriage." Again, I had this moment of
like, I haven't heard anyone speak in
these ways outside of my, you know what
I mean, my upbringing in like 30 years
ago. And here's this like rock star kind
of like rediscovering the beauty of so,
you know what I mean? I'm like, what is
going on? Um, but but what what is going
on there? Right? Because see, I'm I'm
really not trying to kind of establish
some rule or something. Instead, I think
what Kravitz is picking up on is
um is is really what the best of the
Christian tradition has been naming for
a very long time. In fact, the way he
put it in the interview, he said, "Well,
this for me, this is a spiritual
commitment." That's the language he
used, a spiritual commitment. And I I
think I think he's clueing in, you know,
that in essence sex is not it's never
just sex. They're like sex it it's it's
more than just a physical act. There
absolutely is a kind of depth dimension
to it. There is something spiritual even
divine about desire and aeros. And when
used um kind of beautifully and
thoughtfully
uh in what I'll just call like a like a
committed um longer term relationship.
I'll leave it to your small groups.
That's one of the small group questions
this week is like what do you think are
like the certain boundary that you know
I'll leave it to y'all to kind of hammer
out. I'm really not up here to to I
don't know come down hard like if you're
outside of marriage, you know. Um I hope
you can get the spirit of what I'm
getting at is I really just I want to
put aos and agape back together. I'd say
that's the like that's the the heart of
the thing. And and so when aos can be in
the context of a long-term loving
committed relationship, then I think sex
really does become this beautiful means
of God's grace in our lives. Or at least
it can become that, right? A place where
we desire and are desired. A place where
we love and are loved. And of course,
that's a long way
from get consent and do what you will.
But I really believe nothing less will
mirror the language in scripture of
aeros and agape. Whether it's a song of
songs, a love poem read allegorically as
being about our erotic desire and love
for God and her desire for us. Or the
book of Hosea which explores the idea of
God as jealous lover. Or the book of
Jeremiah with its beautiful passage
where the Lord says, "I've loved you
with an everlasting love. Therefore, I
have drawn you with loving devotion. You
can hear the agape and aeros in that,
can't you? The everlasting language,
sacrificial, unconditional, and at the
same time, I've drawn you, desire you,
right? That's it's aeros. I think this
is love at its best. Aeros and agape
meeting in one body, in one person, and
in one relationship. May we all give
expression to that in every aspect of
our lives. sexual or otherwise. In the
name of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit.
Amen. So on the
night that Jesus was
betrayed, he had one final meal with his
disciples. And at that meal, he held up
a loaf of bread and he broke it. And he
said, "Take and eat. This is my body.
It's broken for you." And then he held a
cup of wine. He said, "Take and drink.
This is my blood. It's shed for you.
whenever you eat this bread, whenever
you drink this cup, remember me. And so
for 2,000 years, Christians have
gathered at the table to to remember, to
commune, to connect uh with Christ. So
the way we'll participate in communion
tonight is we'll just go rowby row.
We'll start here at the front and we'll
just form a line and when one row is
done, the next one can go ahead and come
forward. Um you can feel free to kind of
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some people like to take immediately,
some like to come and kneel here at the
front where you can return to your seat,
but no one will lead you through the
exact moment of partaking of the
elements. And uh finally, we practice
what's called an open table. So, if
you're here tonight and you'd like to
participate, then you're you're free to
do that. U at the same time, if you
don't want to, that's that's perfectly
okay, too. Just know the red is wine,
the white is grape juice. So this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more. So come come you who have much
faith and you who have little. You who
have been here often and you who have
not been here long. You who have tried
to follow and you who feel like you
failed. Come. Come because it's the Lord
Jesus who invites you and it's his will
that those who want to meet him should
meet him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
You guys are welcome to stay seated for
this last song. Just thought tonight we
would close with a love song.
[Music]
So I have a
tendency to laugh it all the wrong
moments.
[Music]
Sometimes I forget the words to my own
song. I'm not the silent type or an exit
sign or a yellow brick
roof. You are the one thing that I
know. It's in the wine we
drink. Dirty dishes in the kitchen sink.
In the lights go out till the sun comes
up. We are not
alone. It's in the miles we
drive. Never having to say goodbye. It's
the things we tell each
other without saying a
word. You are the one that I know.
[Music]
There's a
beauty that we never know just what the
future
holds beneath the
[Music]
surface. We are the calm. We are the
storm.
Not a sunset or a hurricane or a
Vinc. You are the one thing that I know.
It's in the wine we drink.
Dirty dishes in the kitchen sink. And
the lights go out till the sun comes up.
We are not
alone. It's in the miles we drive.
Never having to say goodbye to the
things we tell each
other without saying a
word. You are the one thing that I
[Music]
know. It's in the wine we drink.
Dirty dishes in the kitchen sink and the
lights go out till the sun comes up. We
are not
alone. You are the one thing that I
know. You are the one that I know.
[Music]
Thank you so much for joining us this
evening. If you're new, we would love
for you to fill out a visitor's card. Um
you can do that at the table on your way
out or via the QR code. Um but if you
can take the time, we'd greatly
appreciate it. Um don't forget next
week, no service. Um, and if you'd like
to sign up for the wheelchair
accessibility thing, uh, also scan the
QR code. That's where you can do that.
Um, generosity is a key aspect of a life
of adoration and worship. If the table
is your church home, then we invite you
to scan the QR code and give financially
or visit the t the
tabletx.org. Let me send you into this
week with a blessing. You can stand or
just hold your hands in a posture of
receiving. Um, as I speak these
words, you are a child of
God. You are a child of
God. This is true on your best day and
it is true on your worst day. So, as you
go into your week ahead with its yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between, go filled with
the assurance that you are loved, you
are worthy, and you are accepted just as
you are. Go fill with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact
with. Be blessed and we'll see you back
here in two weeks.
[Music]
In the wine we
drink, dirty dishes in the kitchen sink.
And the lights go out till the sun comes
up. We are not
alone. It's in the miles we drive.